Well, good morning church.
It's great to be together as we encourage one another,
as we spur one of the on to love and good deeds through singing, through giving,
through fellowshipping together and through giving
in all the ways that we'll talk about today. Now,
you are not just a spectator here today. Uh, you are never just a spectator.
You are an active key participant and we're gonna see that very clearly today in
the book of First Corinthians.
So go ahead and turn there with me if you have your copy. God's word,
first Corinthians chapter 12. It's where we're going to be
and it's easy to find an illustration for today because it's all over
this passage. Uh, threaded throughout is the illustration of the human body.
And the human body is an amazing machine, isn't it?
There are at least 11 distinct systems and
thousands of body parts that have to work together in order for the body to work
and function properly and we'll.
We all understand when we really think about it,
how important and how interdependent each part of the body actually is.
Like the lungs need the heart to pump the oxygen to all the parts of the body.
The the stomach needs teeth to grind up the,
the food and the esophagus to carry it to the stomach and other
parts to eliminate it, right? Like you see the, the stomach needs other things.
And before you think any part of your body is unimportant,
just wait until your gallbladder goes bad, right? Or,
or you see that your thyroids go haywire or you stub your little toe.
Even the infamous appendix
probably functions as some sort of probiotic storage unit. But anyway,
we can get into that later. Ask a doctor about it.
But if we understand the implications of our physical bodies and how
each part is important, how interdependent each part is on the others,
why don't we see that clearly spiritually?
One Corinthians 1227 says that you, that's a plural. You,
you together are the body of Christ and individually members
of it. See,
that's why I feel like all this is so important today because every one of us
is tempted by our consumeristic self-centered culture
to live our lives as if we were a cutoff body part
that we're just a liver lying alone on a table somewhere where we're a
finger cutoff or as Ryan said last year, we're an eyeball in a fridge.
Like thi this is what we are tempted to live like.
And that's obviously true of you if you never or rarely attend,
if you're never around other believers just in the presence and worship and
community, that's true of you cut off. But listen,
you can still be here all the time and still live a cutoff life.
You might pridefully think that you can make it on your own,
but the Bible actually commands us to serve one another with
the gifts that God has given us. One Peter four 10 says,
as each has received a gift, use it to serve one another.
Like you can't get any more clear than that. In fact,
Ephesians four further says,
that's actually how we grow as a church,
both ourselves and others, but also the church as a whole,
as we each use our gifts.
This is what Ephesians four verses 15 and 16 says,
speaking the truth in love, we are to grow up in every way into him.
Who is the head into Christ? From whom?
The whole body that's us joined and held together by every joint with which it's
equipped, when each part is working properly,
makes the body grow so that it builds itself up in love.
So that's the truth today. Really simple. I need to grow.
You need to grow. So use your gift.
And if you remember nothing else, it's simple. I need to grow. You need to grow.
So use your gift.
That's how the Apostle Paul started this section in one Corinthians 12.
He's talking further about what we call spiritual gifts.
Ephesians four earlier explained that those come from God and
Paul's explaining to the Corinthians what those things are about.
And so as we're thinking about the fact that we all need to use our gifts,
the the summary of this first section in first Corinthians 12 is that God
uniquely gifts in equal ways,
God uniquely gifts in equal ways.
I'm wanna read verses four through 11 of one Corinthians 12 to start with where
we'll see that that truth I just said. Verse four,
there are varieties of gifts, but the same spirit,
there are varieties of service, but the same Lord,
there are varieties of activities,
but it's the same God who empowers them all in everyone.
To each is given the manifestation of the spirit for the common good,
for to one is given through the spirit, the utterance of wisdom and to another,
the utterance of knowledge according to the same spirit,
to another faith by the same spirit to another gifts of healing by the one
spirit to another, the working of miracles to another, prophecy to another,
the ability to distinguish between spirits to another,
various kinds of tongues to another, the interpretation of tongues.
All these verse 11,
all these are empowered by one and the same spirit who
apportions to each one individually as he wills.
Now there are nine unique gifts listed in this little section here, but,
but know that this,
this list is not exhaustive 'cause there are actually other lists a couple
different times in the New Testament.
And so some would actually identify over 30 unique
spiritual gifts throughout the New Testament,
adding in things like teaching mercy, evangelism, administration,
even craftsmanship. You can kinda make an argument for that.
There's a number of other things that we would claim to be spiritual gifts,
really could be anything that God gives to you to use for his glory. I mean,
you could see that as in a sense, a spiritual gift as well.
But here's the point,
the point I want you to see is that our gifts are very different, right?
The first thing here is that our gifts are all very different.
It says there are varieties of gifts in verse four.
Even the ways they play out is different. Even the way God uses them, it,
it is all very different in how it shows up.
Yet they're all from the same God.
Did you see how many times from the same spirit, verse four says the Spirit,
the Lord in verse five, God gives it in verse six.
So this is all from God with one purpose.
That's why there should be no division over the gifts within the church.
That was a problem in Corinth.
Paul's talking to a church that had problems over dividing over the spiritual
gifts and he says, no, no, it shouldn't be that way. In fact,
this pretty plainly states that each gift is equally important, right?
Our gifts are very different,
but our gifts are just as important as one another's 'cause. Again,
over and over,
the same spirit dishes out the gifts to each member
individually. Verse 11 said, as he wills,
like this is his call,
it's up to him as he wills and his gifting is part of
what scripture calls his grace to you. In fact,
that word grace has the same root word as gift
and, and scripture ties those things together. We talk about God's grace to us.
This is actually part of it. Like in one Peter four 10,
as each has received a gift,
use it to serve one another as good stewards of God's varied grace.
Same thing first, uh, Ephesians four, seven says, God's spiritual gifts,
his people,
but grace was given to each one of us according to the measure of Christ's gift,
Romans 12, six,
having gifts that differ according to the grace given to us,
let us use them. So this is God's gift.
His grace to you is that you have a unique gift from
him to use in God's gracious plan
as part of his grace towards you,
he's created you and designed you and gifted you with what you need to
fulfill his plan for your life.
You don't have to wonder if he's given you what you need.
He's given it to you by his grace. Now,
we don't know why he does some for this gift and some for this. That's his deal.
You can debate with him, take it up there.
But verse seven, notice what it says
to each is given the manifestation of the spirit for the common good,
it's for the common good.
That means every believer to each, every believer has been given a,
a unique way for the Holy Spirit to show off within
the local church.
A way that verse seven says is for the common good,
each gift is for the common good. It's not anything meant to build yourself up,
it's meant for others. Remember each Ephesians four said,
when each part is working properly, that's when we all grow.
This is for the good of the body. The tendency, though,
the tendency in the church is for us to place more of an emphasis on the very
public gifts like teaching or pastoring. That that alone,
that is, that is what causes the church to grow.
But this says no, this says,
whatever gift you've been given is just as important as anything else
is for the growth of this body. So use it.
So use it. But you might be thinking something like this, okay,
I I hear you. I, I get, I should be, but, but, but,
but I've never been to seminary. Like I don't, I don't,
I don't have the training that I need to, to do what I'm supposed to do.
I don't know if I could serve like those other people serve when I see them
serving, I, I don't know if I could.
That's why this last piece here is so important that our gifts are all
empowered. Our gifts are very different.
Your gift is just as important as mine is, but they're all empowered.
You see it very clearly. Look at verse six again.
There are varieties of activities,
but it is the same God who empowers them all in everyone.
And then down in verse 11, again,
all these gifts are empowered by one in the same spirit,
right? These, these words empower. So, so check this out.
God distributes these gifts as he sees fit. That's up to him.
But he doesn't just leave us hanging to figure out how to do 'em.
And we don't have to figure it out on our own how we can make this work and make
that happen. No, he empowers them. When we do it in our own strength,
we're gonna fail. When we lean on his strength,
we grow and the body grows in Christ's likeness.
I love how the apostle Paul said it in Colossians chapter one,
verses 28 and 29. This is a passage we're gonna get to in a few weeks.
We're gonna start working through Colossians next Sunday,
all the way through the end of the fall. But verses 28 and 29 of Colossians one,
this is very clear. Paul says him, we proclaim Jesus.
We proclaim warning everyone,
teaching everyone with all wisdom that we may present,
everyone mature in Christ. Remember, that's the goal of Ephesians four,
the body to grow in Christ's likeness. Verse 29, for this,
I toil that word is like, man, I'm working as hard as I can,
struggling with all his energy that
he powerfully works within me.
Is that not a profound shift? Like he's saying, I'm Morgan as hard as I can,
but this, this word he says that he his power,
it's the same word we saw in one Corinthians 12,
empowering the gifts that God himself says,
here's how you do it. Here's the strength to do it.
And so I know it might feel like a struggle.
Some of you've been serving a long time, you feel like it's a grind,
it's a long haul.
But some of you might be on the other side of this saying, I,
I don't know if I could ever do that.
I don't know if I could start serving in any way. Listen this,
if we rely on him, it's God's strength who gives you what you need to do,
what he's called you to do.
The only way you can do what you're called to do is by his strength that he
powerfully works within you. Paul said in Colossians one,
so God uniquely gifts in equal ways,
and then he empowers those gifts for the common good.
And so Paul sets that up and then he shifts into this
illustration, says, here's what the spiritual gifts all mean.
Here's how it works. Then he,
he shows us visually with the body metaphor, what it looks like.
So he starts in verse 12 of one Corinthians 12, 12 and 13. Look at this.
He says four, which means he ties it to what he just said,
for just as the body is one and has many members
and all the members of the body, though many are one body.
So it is with Christ.
For in one spirit we were all baptized into one body, Jews or Greeks,
slaves or free and all were made to drink of one spirit.
Is that not beautiful language about unity?
Does it not show us how critical it is for very different people
to function like they are one body? And listen,
we're not talking about uniformity where everybody is exactly the same.
We're talking about unity in the midst of the diversity.
And that is what shows God off to the world.
I mean, Paul here talks about Jews and Greeks, slaves and free,
those were historic enemies, had nothing to do with each other.
And he says, no, actually they've been brought together as one.
Ephesians two is a beautiful picture of that.
Here's how it's been said recently that the most dynamic evangelistic power
of the gospel comes when the world is forced to sit up and take notice
that people are loving each other in ways it cannot account for with humanistic
presuppositions.
Meaning the world has to look at this and say there's no reasonable explanation
for that. That those people would love each other
like different ethnic groups and single parent families and multi parent
families. And, and then you've got, you've got this, this dynamic of,
of rich and poor and,
and you've got people who are really high up in the world and lowly in the world
like and they all love each other.
That doesn't make sense to the world. But that's what the point here is,
is that God diversely saves into one body.
Like there is a wide range of people in this room right now,
all different.
And yet he saves into one body through
faith in Jesus' life, death and resurrection. That's the unifier
and the ceiling of the Holy Spirit.
That's what he's talking about the end of verse 13.
If you have believed turn from your sin, turn to Jesus,
that means you are saved into this one body,
Jesus's body in
the midst of that beautiful diversity.
There's a beautiful equality in that. There's one purpose.
Then we're not just saved as a smattering of people all sitting around together.
We're saved as one body with Christ as the head for one purpose to
follow what our head would say to do
altogether E equally.
So what that means first is that you are important.
That means you are important.
And I'm talking when I point my finger at this one person right here,
all of you, you are important. If there's unity within this body,
you are important.
And so Paul takes this body metaphor and he shows us that a very clear and kind
of humorous way. Look at verse 14 through 20,
for the body does not consist of one member, but of many.
If the foot should say, because I'm not a hand, I don't belong to the body,
well that would not make it any less a part of the body, right?
If the ear should say, because I'm not an eye, I don't belong to the body,
I would not make it any less a part of the body because if the whole body were
an eye, where would be the sense of hearing if the whole body were an ear,
where would be the sense of smell. But as it is,
God arranged the members in the body, each one of them as he chose.
If all were a single member,
where would the body be as it is?
There are many parts, yet one body.
So you remember in the first section, he's,
he's willing which gift people get here,
he has chosen how the body is arranged. That's what Paul is explaining,
his spiritual gift teaching with this body metaphor. He says, God picked it,
God assign. Now again, you could sit there and you could debate with God.
You could lament why you're not gifted to preach or why you're not gifted
musically or why you're not gifted like that person. You could do all of that.
But see, this
you friend are critically important to the body with what you've been
given every one of you.
'cause listen, according to what he just said,
we're not just one big mouth chattering away like those windup teeth that kind
of go on the table, right? It's not a, it's not the body
or man, some of you remember this movie Fly to the Navigator way back eighties,
nineties, somewhere in there like the eye that floats in, right?
We're not just one big eye looking at the world like this is the body together.
And think about it.
The hand cannot fulfill its complete function without the arm and the shoulder
and the heart beating blood to it. And the, the nerves signaling where to go.
Like the, the hand cannot do what it does without the body.
The mouth cannot speak without the lungs forcing air through vocal cords.
And you see, like you could go all the way into this,
the ears can't hear any further unless the feet get them somewhere else to
hear that bird chirping over them.
Just because you're not gifted in one way or another,
that does not mean you are a less important part of the body to
God designed the body this way.
Listen, that's why celebrity should never be a part of the church
since no one person has all the spiritual gifts. It's not about one person.
We need one another and we are all vitally important
because here's what happens when everybody's serving,
when each one is working properly, Ephesians four,
it allows each person then to pull back and say, okay,
what is my unique gift?
And focus on that and do that exclusively when everybody else is doing what
they're supposed to be doing.
It allows you to be better at what you've been called to do in Ephesians four,
that's how we grow into Christ's likeness.
So how do you use your gift? Okay, you see, I need to, I need to do this,
all right, how do I do it first Again, remember, it's in God's strength,
it's empowered by God. You can't just go do this yourself.
You rest in the Lord for his power.
But I do wanna give you a couple practical examples of how you can serve,
how you can do what God's called you to do.
We're gonna put a slide up on the screen.
You're gonna see this and it's gonna be a lot of information really quickly,
but I want to just caveat something.
You might think that in a big church like this,
all the opportunities are filled. If there's not a place for you,
it's all easily filled up because there's so many people around. Well,
not so fast, my friend, as Lee Corso would say,
there are lots of ways to plug in and serve here.
It's just a sample list. By the way, we didn't pull everything.
We just open spots in a few different areas.
And so I'll just walk through some of this.
Maybe you're administratively gifted and you can help organize events
for our foster and adoption ministry that's growing right now,
or special needs ministry that needs help or,
or connections to help people feel included into our church.
Really anything could use administrative help, right?
Maybe you're musically gifted and you can help lead worship on Sundays and other
times for us,
maybe you're gifted with hospitality and you can be a greeter and you can make
people feel warm and welcome just by showing up.
Or you can serve on our care team to make sure people feel connected and cared
for and loved.
Maybe you're a gifted teacher and you can help lead a a community group or you
can help lead a a kid's group on Sundays or Wednesdays.
Maybe you're gifted with craftsmanship and you can help
take care of the building. You can be build some needed resources around here.
And listen,
some of this stuff is not necessarily because you have the gift to do it,
it's just because it's a way for you to serve others. Listen,
there is is no spiritual gift of baby holding, okay? Right there.
You don't have to have a spiritual gift to to do that, right?
But you know what that does?
That serves that young parent who can be in here knowing their baby's taken care
of back there and they can focus, right? So,
so that's just a way to serve your brothers and sisters around you and care for
people in that here's an added benefit.
Serving is also one of the best ways to feel more connected to the church.
You know, lifeway Research just did a study, it was pretty piercing.
They, they surveyed church attenders all across the country
and 84% of people said that their church encouraged them to serve.
But only 30% had served anywhere in the last year.
And so we wonder why we feel so disconnected from the church.
The best way is when you get to serve with people and you're right alongside 'em
on a mission trip where you're serving in kids or in the cafe or anything else.
You just get to be, and my ours might be higher. I don't know.
Ours might be lower, I don't know. But anyway, there's,
there's a whole lot of disconnected and spiritually stunted people in the
churches in America because this is part of the deal.
I'll, but I also want you to hear me in this.
There are many ways for you to serve with your gift that are
unseen, that don't have a title, don't have a position.
Think of the gift of wisdom to be able to speak into somebody's life in a
disciple making relationship that's not up there.
But how needed
or the gift of mercy where every Sunday you walk in these doors and your
mind is to look for people, you're scanning the room and you're asking, God,
who do you want me to sit by today? Who do you, who do you want to lead me to?
Who needs somebody to care for 'em right now?
Because it might be their last chance at church.
And they show up and they're like, God, if you don't move today, I'm out.
And it could be you to sit next to them and be that reconnection point.
That's the gift of mercy. It's not up there. But, but just live with that.
The gift of faith. Like just think of the,
the list of widows and widowers that I send a letter to every Monday.
The gift of faith that they have to just battle in prayer for me,
for our family and for the church. You don't see that,
but it's a gift. And we could go on and on and on. But to each remember,
to each is given the manifestation of the spirit for the common good,
for the body's growth.
Even if it's behind the scenes and nobody even knows you're doing it.
It's for the good of the body. We are many parts.
Yet one body,
see church culture in America is so consumeristic
like, what's in it for me? What do I get out of this?
If I don't like what I'm receiving, I'm gonna go somewhere else, right?
It's just, it's all about me. It's all about what I get out of this. No,
the picture here is of service to others.
Like you show up because you're like, how can I care for other people?
How can I serve other people today?
Use your gift.
You are important to this.
But also remember this.
That means they are valuable too.
You are important,
but that also means they meaning everybody else around you are valuable too.
We are to cherish these other parts around us.
See, Paul continues with this metaphor verses 21 through 26.
He says, the eye cannot say to the hand, I have no need of you,
nor again the head to the feet. I have no need of you.
On the contrary, the parts of the body that seem to be weaker,
are indispensable.
And on those parts of the body that we think less honorable,
we bestow the greater honor.
And our unpresentable parts are treated with greater modesty,
which our more presentable parts do not require.
But God has so composed the body,
giving greater honor to the part that lacked it,
that there may be no division in the body,
but that the members may have the same care for one another.
If one member suffers, all suffer together.
If one member is honored, all rejoice together.
And so again, each gift is very different. Each part is very distinct,
but everyone is just as important to the function of the body as anyone else's.
He in fact used the word indispensable.
That means no one can be excluded.
In fact,
what we discover here is a highlighting of those parts that might seem less
worthy, that might feel like they're less honorable,
that might feel less important. Paul says no. In fact,
we should highlight and encourage them because there's no division here.
We're all on the same team. It's not just about the few of us who are public,
right? This is a universal team. One body,
God wants us to have a mutual concern for others simply because
that person is also Gods.
Not because of what they can or can't do. That doesn't matter.
It's that that's God's person, that's a member of our body,
that is God's image bearer. And we care for them.
In fact, I love the picture.
Verse 26 paints here of the interconnectedness of the body.
Like when you get a scalp massage, your whole body enjoys that, right?
Like the tingle you get. It's just, this is great.
So every every part is rejoicing with the one who's honored. But but also,
you know it's true. When you break your arm,
your whole body suffers because of it, right? It's limited,
it hurts with the arm. And I think, listen,
I think this is one huge area where we have missed it in the local church,
in the, the modern church has missed this.
'cause one of the most common things that we hear,
one of the most common themes we hear when talking with people in crisis
is that they feel alone.
That no one is with them.
Now listen, they might have a bunch of people around them.
They might be sitting by a lot of people on Sundays.
They might have a lot of people around them in their neighborhoods,
but they feel alone.
One Corinthians 12 says, we're interconnected though,
that we're not just a bunch of disconnected body parts sitting near one another
in a room. We are interconnected.
And so think about this.
Do we even know when other members are suffering?
Do we even care that other people are hurting?
It
doesn't seem like it because we sure walk around like everything's fine.
How you doing? I'm fine. How you doing? I'm good.
It can't happen here. We,
we have to make sure that no one feels alone.
We have to make sure that we, we have a, a culture,
an atmosphere that allows people to get real, to get vulnerable and say,
I'm not okay. Like how you doing? Pretty terrible right now.
And you actually say, okay, well let's talk through it.
Instead of just looking at 'em like they're crazy and walking away.
Because one Corinthians 12 indicates suffering together
is more than just walking with someone through that issue.
Like how often have you heard or said, Hey, I'll be there if you need me.
If you need anything, let me know. How often do you get called?
Rarely, right? Because it doesn't really seem like care, but,
but this says no, we need to enter into it with them. That's the idea.
Suffering with them. They suffer together.
That means you're actually in it with them.
I love the phrase I hear from firefighters. Firefighters say it this way,
when others run out, we run in.
Should that not be true of the church? Everybody's abandoning,
everybody's leaving and saying, no, I don't wanna deal with that.
That's too hard. We run in and care.
Like just this Tuesday at our staff meeting,
a church staff meeting,
we had more than a few staff members open up very vulnerably about
deep struggles and pain in their life.
Cancer feelings of depression,
friends dying. They don't know what to say.
And listen, I love the fact that there's,
there's a culture of freedom that says it's okay for me to say that
I'm struggling right now, that I'm not okay,
that I need help. That that's okay on a staff, a church staff.
And we can say, listen, I'm struggling with this right now.
I don't know what to do. I don't have the answer.
It's hard to believe God right now. Like that's what we're saying.
And so what we did is we gathered around them,
we prayed over 'em and and we just suffered with them.
We carried those needs to the Lord and we, we shed tears together.
It was incredibly sweet.
Now the challenge will be continuing that ministry for the long haul.
Not just once and forget about it, but actually carrying for it.
But here's the reality.
If I'm too busy to sit with someone in pain,
then I'm too busy, period. Right?
If you're too busy to care for someone in need, you're too busy.
What's more important?
It's the heart of the gospel, right? Jesus who,
who came not to be served but to serve.
He ran into our pain when everybody else ran out.
He carried our sin on the cross.
He suffered with us. This is the heart of the gospel.
So when was the last time that you entered into a brother's or sister's pain?
Not just that, I'll pray for you, but entered feeling it with them.
You felt the abuse they endured in some way
you hurt with their pain over a loss.
Listen, some parts of the body may not be very public. No,
but they are worthy of honor too.
This is a way to honor because God designed them for a vitally important
aspect of the body's function. If they're hurting, we should hurt with them.
And it may just be what they provide for the body,
just the faith to endure really hard things
like it's so life-giving,
encouraging to me when I know many stories in this room and I look out here and
I'm preaching about trusting God and I'm watching people who've trusted God
through way harder stuff I've ever faced.
And they're still believing and raising their hands and crying and saying,
Jesus, you're my everything.
That's the gift of faith that builds me up.
So, so encouraging. And so let's shift our focus away from ourselves,
consumerism and it's about me and shift it on to those people around
us.
'cause we finally get to verse 27 here,
which is a great summary of everything that I've said today.
I said at the beginning, but verse 27 says,
now you are the body of Christ and individually members of it.
This is who we are, church.
We are a local and expression of the
global and eternal body of Christ.
And as we've seen, we have every gift and we have every part.
We need to fulfill the purpose that God has ordained for this body.
We can't do everything. We shouldn't try to do everything,
but we can do what God's called us to do.
That means we can go on the mission that he uniquely has for us.
We can grow as he intended for us to grow.
And we can care for people as he intended us to care for people.
We have everything.
We have everything we need to do.
What Jesus' physical body would've been doing while he was here on this earth.
We are the body of Christ. Now,
what was Jesus doing? We do
only though, remember only if each part is working properly.
It's been said that in a land still heavily influenced by a heritage of
rugged individualism,
believers need to work ever harder to demonstrate that Christianity is not a
merely personal religion, but is fundamentally corporate.
What that means is that it is absolutely a personal relationship with
Jesus,
but it must lead to interpersonal relationships with other Christians.
This is part of what it is.
You are the body of Christ and individually members of it.
But when we do that, listen, one of our values is reimagine generosity.
When we rethink how we give with our lives,
when we walk in here as an investor, not a consumer,
when we live our entire lives all week, looking out for others,
caring for others, when that's what we are doing, listen,
that's when we are all blessed, right?
Is that not a blessing? Would that kind of church not be a blessing,
a blessing to us? Each one of us? We'd all benefit from that.
But then think of the blessing. It would be to the world
because your neighbor, my neighbor, is looking for hope.
My neighbor's looking for value. Our neighbors are looking for connection.
And what they would see is a true faith family empowered to live
out what Jesus has commanded. What a blessing.
So we rely on God's spirit for his power.
But church, let's be that. Let's be that kind of church, right?
What a blessing.